most likely to throw their Club after a
bad shot I've actually done it San
Antonio La quinteta four iron was not
good to me that day did you get it back
I did never came out my bag again though
who's most likely to load up on snacks
at the turn both hot dogs and ice cream
sandwiches turkey sand popcorn if they
got it they mostly
I mean probably neither of us yeah we're
just playing play the course guy yeah
insist on walking instead of using the
cards this guy this guy traditionally
yes not me that's definitely me it's
likely to Taco their partner is teeing
off probably me but it could be
Stephanie it could be me if like the
kids are coming it's a lot yes